hey guys drag outfit here Dan cyber here
for that cyber channel on YouTube and
twitch TV and also for the TGM squadron
on youtube.com slash user slash games
following all these things
III reactions they keep coming they keep
going and we're late as [ __ ] it's like
tricks trans actors anthem here we go
there's a teaser trailer watch I'm
excited people are jacked about this
this is like did she act like the V game
that you know like II freeze always got
like the game then it's not like me game
this is the first one right
it's like original yeah it's those
original games original game its Bioware
you know it's going to be me
or die trying
[Music]
cool access I like it
[Music]
the story doesn't end here alright
doesn't give you much on it other than
we're exploring a world and you got
these experts that seem like he can do
some cool [ __ ] let's just watch the
gameplay that's the stuff of Morgan
family hi I'm John Warren Game Director
for Anthem and so this is all engaged oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
[Music]
just look like you had to eat right yeah
after weed crackling freelancer big
trouble baby big trouble why did you do
mistake
wonderful hired some people they weren't
freelancers I know they said they could
handle it and the price is right
I thought maybe unbelievable you're
right it was stupid
I'm sorry but they're still out there
somewhere
did you just bring them back anything
you need
all the money you have hell or high
water in advance of you and your friends
or freelancers the hero's elite the
safety of the walls of ports are six
explore the unknown
humanity is doing two players that they
head out on an expedition hey huh
you ready to go Scout some supplies
already hopefully thank everyone I was
going to go with the Colossus oh I'm
going to use my ranger traps when you
upgrade how's it going customized [ __ ]
that's awesome but if we want to be easy
like bad like scripting ball 9 player
like trailers I hate me doesn't work
that they never sound natural it's like
okay I better do this one place rather
than kosis we call Jeff
shall we three players super to
incapabilities heavily penalized ellipse
looking play looking good
beep got a warrior eclipse Wow
Wow yay open world kill those animals
just go who threw the bat open maybe
explore with differences oh I'm an
artist until you please Wow Oh Chelsea
what's up yeah the girls a vamp in
exhaustion and threats in come from any
direction it's a dynamic and unexpected
incident every corner
I'm not sure when solar supplies on the
sky come on Silas
yeah he seems like a problem but yeah
York I'll go back up I speak the
heaviness oh no no he's like
Wow now that you'll that is cool that is
a real open-world game right yeah oh my
god so cool so pretty - yeah absolutely
hey hey there all right harder than
their yeah haven't see that later it
came and Betty coils right here I could
hate these up and down that cool thing
we'll wait for Kim evey for the XP event
that's cool under attack anyone we areas
for our attack
[Music]
and you can equip your javelin exosuit
this gear that brings devastating power
to comments
they're all this guy got a heavy W sub
mortar Commission covering fire cakes
that noggin there's one coming it okay
very good job yeah she's fired my three
times
oh man okay that's awesome
oh good yeah Jared's rest all right I
don't
large-scale world like shaker-style
dynamic and poured you off the beaten
path at the promise of new stories to
discover really
give you stay quality blurry shipping
sharp Oklahoma
okay I'll show that skip to my people
hold on okay
oh look how there's kids with I am today
I just natural
[Music]
oh I don't know
the storms and crazy
[Music]
nice custody flying too
all right you slope and the upside
[Music]
our story about there
[Music]
you know I've heard the word anthem
plenty of times
Anthem Blue Cross the national anthem I
don't exactly know what the word anthem
means them where we going to our
thoughts on this Dan
I need a look at what anthem means
anthem a word meaning he's got it okay I
knew you were trying to write dictionary
but you just got di pain arousing or
uplifting song okay yes don't know
what's gonna happen
oh yeah that's been in hell Mel I heard
nothing happen okay that looks really
cool
all right you see your plans these guys
named freelancers caught that piece of
information right there I can't wait
till they do like an anthem three and
four and they get a lot of hate for all
the changes but now the open world looks
great I mean I think is a crazy world I
mean when you start off and like this
Tatooine type of land yeah and suddenly
you're like you fly a little bit and
then you're in the jungle and then
you're underwater like this is great
underwater I don't want anything with
rested yeah because a lot of open world
stuff we've sort of seen a little bit
before it's cool eek fly around the
going underwater and still flying in the
wind I don't fly at like it looks like
there's stuff to explore under water
it's not just here's the lake there
might be some treasure at the bottom
looks like yo you go underneath here you
hit man after man there's a whole nother
way out there what are you most looking
forward to about this game you are know
something okay
I was thinking of giving destiny to I'm
rethinking it because it is game this
looks this looks like what I thought
didn't knew what was going to be is like
the open world events kind of happening
which I'm sure they're going to be like
schedule 8 on like a timer so you can
find them which is kind of
disappointment but in fact matter is
everyone wants to do them yeah Luke Lutz
always a good thing I like the idea of
you being able to pick what like what
are like strictly X oh yeah you use
that's really cool you can pick and they
say this is a lot of customizing options
the director of it said yeah I'm like
wondering what are all the options you
can really
yeah excited it like you get a yellow
one you give me well I'm just I'm mostly
excited in the fact that with like
destiny is like if I want to play all
the classes or use everything I had to
make three separate characters this is I
make one dude and that I can use
whatever exoskeletal skeleton I want how
many you can have at one time that is I
don't know but it's also real easy for
them to then build new suits or it's
just like hey uh six months in there
like hey isn't this something that I'm
kind of concerned with this is like
story yeah that I I mean I could not
believe anything really off that other
than we need to go out there jammies
yeah like it's got a good world set up
yet seems like it's oh my god it doesn't
similar there's a specific mission
you're on it seems like it's only just
open-world missions right so it's hard
to get a good story when it when that's
the only option yeah I'm good when it's
not like there's not a specific story
you're really following it looks like
just keep choosing a bunch of missions
the whole time yeah it's really going to
be about the online experience too
yeah which is which is fine yeah I mean
grabbing for friends like that yeah
great I like I for is always a solid
number for me as far as like a like a
squad yeah is to have four players
where's like destiny you only you could
only had three per strike or mission or
six if you're doing the raid which I'm
hoping that they have like big huge raid
bosses where you need I get like three
squads together to go fight I mean at
this point in time I'm on board I really
want to see more because I don't want to
invest money like I did in destiny play
it at a friend's place dip to do that
yeah we're gonna spend $60 go over this
is you know forty to get whatever else
Giada yeah yeah alright got a lot of
Assam which is a rousing or a blipping
song identify with a particular group
body or cause which would be the
freelancers yes subscribe to the real
reject put that notification bell tgn
squadron he is a part of youtube.com
slash user slash games most importantly
that cyber channel on twitch.tv and on
YouTube all game you're related all
around games
called an is he just a game show just
for fine talking to no one is portrait